I was very pleased to introduce rob was
going to talk to
I turned data and web visualization some
of you might know him from Vincent and
he is currently a full stack engineer at
at data pad and before that is done work
in aerospace and naval architecture so
please welcome Rob Thanks thank you okay
you guys all hear me yeah all right so
up and down the Python data and web
visualization stack this is kind of a
terrible title actually I didn't know
what to call this talk so I said all
right well I'm gonna talk about data n
I'm going to talk about like Python web
biz so that's what i'll call it um hi
I'm Rob here's the here's the link to my
talk there's my twitter handle emotion
kid Billy I I tweeted out both both this
repo and the NB viewer version which
which mostly works I'd recommend that
you actually run the notebook um live
because some of the interactive
javascript stuff needs to be running
live I work for data pad if any of you
guys saw wes's talk you saw kind of what
we're building I'm biased because I work
there but I think it's awesome and if
you're interested in being a beta tester
you can sign up at data patio and and
we're hiring so if you if you're
interested in distributed systems or
writing analytics code in C or data
visualization come talk to me send us an
email like we're very interested in
talking to you because we're kind of
always looking for people so
visualization in Python we've come a
long way and a long way since I actually
started running Python which wasn't that
long ago so there's probably about three
years ago I was working a company called
vestas wind turbine manufacturer and
investors is very much a matlab company
I mean the company probably has a
thousand seats of malla which is quite a
bit of money you think about it it's
being spent on matlab and I finally I
got fed up there was one day where I was
trying to do something it was like I
needed I needed the matlab statistics
package which is actually something you
have to pay for in matlab statistics
don't come with the with the standard of
a lie package zygarde i'm done but i'm
going to learn a new language and so I
was like all right it came down to
basically our CFD group was using Python
and some guys in my group we're using
our and I was like well what you wish to
I wonder years i think i'm gonna do a
lot of data viz and honestly i almost
picked up are just because ggplot
existed in our
and didn't exist in Python right and and
so what do we have in Python at that
point you know three years ago well 2012
we have matplotlib and it was kind of
like the dominant the dominant dataviz
library and still really is I mean
there's a lot of Matt pot living that
goes on there's also Chaco some of you
might not be as familiar with choco
choco did some really cool stuff with
like real-time data streaming it's very
very neat library so fast forward two
years where are we now well we kind of
have all these libraries now we have all
these different ways to visualize
visualize data in Python and I'm going
to try to hit on every one of these
except for vista p at least a little bit
there have been other talks here getting
really kind of deeply into some of these
libraries like there's a boca talk
yesterday there's a ggplot talk
yesterday so i'm going to kind of touch
on each one and hopefully and they'll
expose you guys that there's a library
that you've never seen before they go I
can visualize data and Python using this
using this library and then you know
it's nice to have it's nice to have a
tool belt so talking about the tool belt
I've heard I've heard this a number of
times like in person and on Twitter and
people say I doesn't all these people
building Python charting libraries like
why doesn't everybody work together and
build one charting library and to me
that seems like why doesn't everyone
work together and work with and write
one programming language like why
doesn't everyone work in one programming
language well you know personally I
think that especially in data viz
choices or signs of a very healthy
ecosystem um I think we need more
visualization libraries that they should
be opinionated and what do I mean by
opinionated I'm not necessarily sure we
need another d3 library that can draw a
line charts and bar charts but we might
need another library that can that can
aggregate and display data in kind of
unique ways and at the end of this talk
I'll kind of demonstrate like a d3
library that it's just drawing line
charts and it's drawing scatter plots
but it's kind of doing so in a unique
way and it's got unique interactions and
I think that's what we need more of like
I think the more data viz libraries we
have the better it is and then that
gives people choices and choices are
good so right now kind of not just the
future is web visualization but the
president is what visualization this
tweets interesting so idly wycombe
author of ggplot
as kind of formally shifted it to
maintenance mode in favor of GG vids and
so what's GG viz well gee gee vidz is
built on top of Vega Vega is is
basically a declarative way to create d3
you know static d3 visualisations and
then Hanley's going full-bore using
using GG vis to render the ggplot2 kind
of idioms and charts so so web biz all
right well we want to build these web
visualizations well how are we going to
build them well likely we've got this
glue and it's called my Python and it
might not surprise you i'm gonna talk
about like I about ipython like everyone
else today is talk to cut out Python so
what does ipython gluing together well
it's gluing together Python in the
browser it's gluing together Python and
JavaScript and as we saw in the last I
thon talk it's gluing together all these
languages and it can actually do all
this inter operatively so you have the
languages that have these libraries that
were rendered III and rendered charts we
can talk to those libraries as was
demoed in the last talk so I python is
our glue for putting all these things
together is you know a really really
powerful tool so these are kind of the
new stacks the new web visualization
snacks in Python and I apologize I I
wrote some of these libraries and I'm
sorry that you know so much of my
stuff's on here but I am going to try to
hit on some of the other important
important libraries that are out there
so if you look at these new stacks I
mean is a stack is like you've got a
Python library that's wrapping some
intermediate library that's wrapping d3
and so this is kind of where web
visualization inside the notebook is
going right now so we've gotten that
fault lip libraries that are kind of
covering up matplotlib swartz and
creating a nice interface to matplotlib
they're being rendered through npl d3
which is Jake van der glasses excellent
excellent package that basically takes
takes matplotlib SVG output and renders
that via d3 and at the notebook so
that's great so I wrote the Vincent
library what Vincent does is it it works
through vega which is another rapper
library of d3 Bagan basically takes a
JSON spec and based on this declarative
JSON spec you can render a chart and
that's really great um you know another
doc I could have done here is like
espousing the value of declarative data
visualization and visualization via via
specs because
if you build your library you know in d3
in JavaScript and if you let it you let
it in just a speck then suddenly it's
its language independent you can render
to that library from any language all
you have to do is have a language that
the feed that serves JSON and basically
any language to do that this point I
mean if you want to write d three charts
in cobol or Fortran that's fine it'll
make JSON you can do that so so those
are the d3 libraries um another couple
libraries I'm going to talk about well
there's bear cart which rickshaw another
d3 rapper goes to d3 and then there's
folium which is leaflet leaflet is a
mapping library it's a very very popular
mapping library right now it serves like
Google Styles slippy tile maps so so
this is kind of the new stack the new
web stack where you have multiple layers
of indirection all most of them ending
at d3 but all of them ending in the
browser so now I'm going to demo and I'm
going to try to show you what all these
libraries to all right so this is my
notebook as you can see the nice thing
about the ipython notebook is it's just
the assessed so you can do it I mean you
can style it ever you want so I feeling
the ipython guys like we're my inputs
and where am I about where the the
brackets are on the code blocks and I
was like adds a presentation I'm just
going to I'm gonna remove remove all
that I can so I've done very minimalist
here on this first this first
initialization so this is actually a
problem this is something that we
authors need to work on in the future
because what's happening in these
initialized notebooks is it's pulling in
all this all this JavaScript and all
these libraries and these libraries are
usually not clobbering each other but I
went through some real pain like all
right what order do i need the qualities
so that so that basically i think is
getting put on the window object are not
collaborating other things so this is
one thing that those of us who are
altering these libraries need to work on
a little bit more and it's nice because
the notebook now has required j/s so
like we can manage our dependencies much
much more cleanly that way all right so
the data I'm going to demo there's a lot
of pandas in here and if if you want to
pull down the notebook and run it
locally you can look at the pan of stuff
I'm not going to talk too much about
pandas pandas has been talked about a
lot here and another other data
conferences
but just quickly the datasets that I'm
going to look at on the FAA and USGS
released a really cool data set every
wind turbine in the United States is in
this data set because you know pilots
need to know where they are so they
don't they don't hit them and the other
one is the other one is wind data that
comes out of the Met masks worked at a
worked at a wind turbine company so this
is the kind of stuff that I like to the
Chop analyze and so basically the first
one is just you know what turbine
manufacturer tower height the second one
is you know kind of streaming streaming
wind speed wind direction data that sort
of thing so not too much exciting going
on there so I'm going to talk about
pinson really quick and so Vincent's the
library i wrote it basically creates
this JSON spec to render through vega to
d3 and and this is this is largely what
Vincent looks like if you're doing it
the hard way Vincent is basically an ORM
on top of on top of Vegas so there's
basically what there's one to one
mapping to all the vega data structures
so to speak so that's really what you're
seeing here is importing these is kind
of verbose things like access properties
and property sets and and that sort of
thing and I'm creating the I'm creating
the chart somewhere in here they are
Vincent bar up top and then I'm
manipulating access properties and
changing font sizes and fills and that
sort of thing and the nice thing about
this is you know all this is this is a
big class hierarchy so once you get
everything built if you want to change a
value you know you can just dot notation
and nest all the way into this really
really quite quite deep JSON spec it's a
it's being created for vaguely and so
what does it look like well with the
Vincent chart you can say all right give
me the grammar what what does this look
like what is my Vegas back look like and
at any point in the nesting hierarchy
you can say grammar and like all right
what am I generating so this is this is
all that Vincent is doing into the hood
it's just generating this this giant
blob of JSON with with various level of
nested properties and values and that
sort of thing and then it's ingesting
data one thing i don't like about
medicine right now that i'd like to
change is it's not very consistent about
how it takes in data in terms of Y data
versus long data
it's kind of a tough thing for charting
library authors to to figure out because
you know really you'd love to just get
tidy data which basically means one row
per observation in your data set and
that's that's really the best way to to
have your data as far as this charting
it goes but most people Zidane is not
like that I mean most people a lot of
people's data especially time series
data comes in like this where every you
know they're a bunch of columns and
you've got a number of observations for
each row and basically if you've ever
used a panda's melt melting is what
turns this data from y too long so you
know that's one thing that Vincent needs
work on as far as getting data in but
you know under the hood it's what it's
doing is it's turning this data into
into long format data essentially so
it's it's a it's saying you know for uh
you know here's the index here's a
column here's the value for those so
it's doing every row get its own gets
its own value all right so you guys want
to see data viz this is alt text hey you
know here's what Vincent's creating you
know it's a bar chart nothing nothing
too exciting they're all that all that
property and access setting we were
doing up there was basically to get to
get this to display correctly because by
default all these all these labels would
clobber each other that sort of thing um
she like oh man I don't know if I want
to use Vincent it's uh it's quite
verbose to get anything anything useful
out of it well I realized that too
because all these projects that i made
like they were just scratching an itch
exercises i was like i want to make
something and I want to make it easier
so i write this library and as I run
into hard corners you know I fix things
so Vincent has some shortcuts that
basically let give you some a little bit
of composability of your charts or you
can kind of do this not very not very
python not very pythonic syntax where
you know i'm wrapping things and
brackets and basically doing kind of a
dot notation to create Vincent charts
and then you know I can create shortcuts
so I'm like all right well I'm going to
want this for every chart so let's run
that function run that function and pass
the chart in and apply all those things
in the future it'd be nice to have some
sort of factory some sort of color
factory we're like I want every chart
that comes out of this factory to have
to have all these settings so what does
that create it's another bar chart great
great Rob you can make bar charts that's
nice what else can you do
alright well you know Vincent can do
stacked areas I'm just going to quickly
kind of run through some of the Vincent
stuff and get some more than some of the
more exciting stuff so Vincent will do
stacked areas it will do group our
charts this isn't a great route bar
chart but the Vincent examples have some
better ones but you know you can do
group bar charts where you've kind of
got categorical variables on the on the
x-axis and you can group by bars you can
you can stack as well the new line plots
can to the line plot you're not a very
good charting library and then it will
do scatter plots so great you know
standard standard chart types to UM then
I depend the nice thing about Vincent is
you can out pull out put all this as the
JSON object and then render it in your
own website so you know outside of the
notebook you know you can you can build
Vincent into some sort of flow or you're
you're creating a JSON spec and paisa
and Python and then just feeding that to
the front end and creating like a
visualization flow in that way so the
next time we're going to talk about
ggplot and so the guys at y hat you know
they bit the bullet for everyone and
they're like all right I'm done we have
to build a ggplot library for python and
and they wouldn't did it and it's quite
good it's not it's not quite as fully
featured as ggplot2 for our yet but
don't give a guy some time they're
working on it they're they're
interesting and so you know what you see
here is very very standard you know GG
idioms as far as like defining
aesthetics and data and then defining a
set of geum's and x labels and why
labels and titles and that sort of thing
so so this is this is I should mention
by the way all this is being rendered as
d 3 by MP ld3 in the notebooks so every
matplotlib library is running through
MPL d3 to render these charts so it's a
it's not it's not a PNG anything like
that it's all being rendered rendered in
JavaScript so thanks thanks Jake van der
plas for for that library to be able to
do this so ggplot you know it will do
things like histograms and that sort of
thing but the next thing that it gives
us it's faceting I don't know how many
of you have ever tried to write facets
in matplotlib but it's it's not fun and
it's extremely verbose there's a lot of
there's a lot of boilerplate code that
goes into place to getting facets to run
I am a plot lib and there's some weed a
little bin with thing here but ggplot
you know it's like oh just give it a
facet rap on a variable and there you go
facets like built-in out of the box it
took me 30 seconds to go from data to
this and and that's really powerful
because you know facets or facets are a
really nice nice visualization tool all
right so now we're getting into some of
the dark magic the interact wit Jets and
the ipython notebook so I'm going to do
another ggplot you know chart and I'm
going to show you how easy it is to use
interactive widgets to like real time
change the data in your plot so I've got
a function it's plotting you know it's
basically charting a line plot that's
it's got some of its got some smoothing
on there and then I just wrap this
function in an interact and interact
decorator and you know it's it's it's
rendering column and I give it give it
the columns as a list and it figures out
what it needs to make as far as the
widget goes so I wrap in the decorator
and suddenly I have this nice little
drop-down menu I'm like oh well I can
change this drop-down and change your
data real time and this is really great
because it means that rather than having
you know 50 charts in my notebook for my
demo I just wrap it with a little
interact with it and suddenly I have
interactive charts and I'm able to
reload different dimensions of the data
and I had to do nothing other than
create a function and add a decorator
and that's really powerful like very
very powerful so so that's ggplot i'm
going to quickly talk about boca there's
way more than i can talk about with this
library like in this talk I just don't
have the time to talk about all the
things that Boca can do it's very very
powerful I'm really happy that they're
working on it and because they've built
in some some really great interactivity
which is just tremendous and part of
what makes Boca greatest so they've got
this little toolbar and you can define
you know you can you can add and remove
tools from this toolbar kind of at will
so what you see happening here is like
all right well I'm going to create a
hover tooltip so now in these tools if
it's if it's an object i create this
hover tool
then it's kind of got this little
templating language at X and X and X Y
and so what it's going to do is if I
hover over if I turn on the hover tool
and over a point it's like all right
this is X this is y and suddenly have
interactive tool tips and all I had to
do is was define a little template for
it and and it was very little work so
anything I've got some really nice you
know I've got panning and they've got
wheels oom so I'm go in and out I can
reset the view they've got bak soon so
there's some great interactivity with
with bokeh plots and it's a library I'd
recommend looking at I'd recommend
looking at their examples there are a
lot of them they've spent a lot of work
creating some some really nice notebooks
and some really some really nice
visualizations so so that's polka and go
check out that project it's really cool
all right so next library this is this
is bear card this is another one that I
wrote and so this is a rapper on
rickshaw which is a library that was
written by Shutterstock focuses on time
series visualization and as far as that
goes like talking about opinionated
libraries this is a good one because
it's very opinionated and what it does
is like we do time series visualization
that's all we do but we try to do it as
well as we can and then we have some
really nice features and some features
that are really nice to have in the
notebook like what are some of these
features well if I just want to view
certain data points I can just turn off
data via the legend so that's really
nice you know if I if I want to drill
down into into single into single
dimensions um in the to do that all I
did was pass in a dataframe specify
color palette height with tell what kind
of plot type I wanted and that was it it
sits there are a couple different plot
types you can do there's bars there's
areas again you know turning turning on
and off data as simple as that so you're
probably wondering all right well what
is that slider slider on the bottom well
bear card also lets you zoom in so this
is actually a bar chart that looks like
an area chart when you zoom far enough
off far enough out and you can do you
can in real time doing so there's Oommen
on data turn off this data and there you
go so this is really nice related for
drilling down into
your data sets you know plotting
plotting a really big a really big
series of data and then drilling down to
a certain time range and I think they
handle tooltips pretty nicely their tool
tips are pretty good so you got a tool
tip over the data point and you've also
kind of got this floating floating
tooltip up top so that's where cart rich
all charts time-series charge if you got
time series and you want to do some
interactivity let's it's pretty good
library all right seabourn so Seaborn is
written by Michael waskom he's a PhD
candidate at Stanford and I wish I'd had
this library two years ago it's
unbelievable library so kind of like
ggplot it focuses on statistical data
viz and and approaching that in kind of
unique ways so this is what Seaborn
calls an LM plot so Seaborn also handles
faceting very very nicely facets are
generated you know I just I'd say called
equals turbine manufacturer suddenly I
passes return by manufacturer very very
very nice and it's got the statistical
visualization stuff built in in interact
wishes I love this this type of chart so
this is nice experts is why but it also
gives you the distributions for each
access really really nice chart so I'm
like all right well want to look at 50
meter wind speed let's look at wind
direction OOP wait a second it goes
alright so there you go interact with
you now we're looking at different
dimensions we can see that whoever put
up this mass did a bad job because what
you want to do when you're measuring
wind is not the mast in front of the
dominant wind direction so clearly the
maps is here the wind is coming from
this direction and it's blocking you
know where you're getting most here went
from so bad job by them but you know now
we can see that because it's easy to
it's easy to change dimensions with the
widgets and again I didn't really have
to do anything i just had to create a
function and wrap it with the interact
decorator in the same vein you know
it'll also handle density so you know
you see in the upper right you can
barely see it you know the params
they're passing the kind like kernel
density create a density plot I think
you can also add distributions to these
to these top and these left and right
char
which is really nice and so you know
it's got histogram charts and you can
also plot extra gram so I'm like all
right well you know I want to plot 1
speed 150-meter weight mean but I kind
of want to look at these different
distributions so I'm go to my tool belt
use the interactive again what does this
look like fits weibull distributed
calculating there you go weibull
distribution on the fly like all right
what about normal distribution so there
you go and then behind the scenes you
know sigh pies calculating things and
then the interactive widget is handling
the rear end during for us so again
interactivity with the widgets very easy
don't be afraid of the widgets are very
very easy to use didn't take me that
long at all to get them to get them
wired up all right so last library
before I talk about kind of a new
library this is library wrote called
folium and petroleum does is it brings
leaflet maps into the notebook and you
can also just generate you know the HTML
itself if you want but Foley and lets
you know it ingests geo jason and pandas
and fill colors and legend names and I'm
like all right well I'm going to see you
know the turbine count per state so like
all right well California and Texas are
doing really well some of the Midwest is
doing well as far as building out wind
power so this is all this is all being
rendered with leaflet the legend that's
just being quantile Bend and pandas and
that's been rendered with d3 but you
know there's a fully interactive chart
it's like any other slippy map where you
can zoom in leaflet also lets you you
know plot points so this is a Solano
Solano is a wind turbines site it's
actually just north of here if you're
flying out of the bay area you can see
it if you know what you're looking for
it's it's just northeast of sweetened
bay but basically with folium you know
you can say i want polygon markers for
each of these each of these rows and the
data frame and then you can specify you
can specify what you want to be in each
of the markers in this case I'm right
I'm like all right well I want to know I
don't know what my idea is so I can just
specify you know all right for each of
these markers right out right out the ID
and there's also a little there's a
little option here called lat low and
pop over and that's basically what you
just saw you can just enable it and
click anywhere on the map
it will enable lat long plot lat long
plot popovers there so the last one kind
of pulls together both folium and
Vincent so these are three wind
measurement stations near Mount Hood I
live in Portland so you know I'm in and
around not a lot so one thing I did the
following month like I see being you
know a use case where people want to
plot points and they also want to know
about data associated with this point so
you can interact you can basically stick
a Vincent chart and a folio and pop over
and you can add charts to your popovers
so basically you can put points on a map
and then you can you can put charts on
those points since though you know you
can't really tell because the data is
very similar but each of these points
has a different chart and and you know
Vincent's doing Vincent's basically
doing the rendering like the chart
creation for the chart itself and then
fo Liam's handling handling the map so
let's quickly go back to this guy so
that was the demo so I you know I'm
sorry I had to run through that a little
bit but give you a very very brief
overview like most of the Python data
Vince libraries where we are right now
so the future what is the future well so
I python has you know has all these
hooks in the Julian are Julian are have
some really great plotting libraries
there's no reason that we couldn't be
reading in the notebook via via Julius
gadfly library via Ars our charts
library and reminisce I'm also not going
to try to pronounce his last name that
the author of the arch arts library has
done an incredible job building out
libraries basically built connectors for
almost every d3 charting library that
exists so if we can get that working in
the notebook like something we have all
these options for charting um so what
else does the future look like well the
ipython guys are doing some work so
we've got these columns you got this
communication layer we've got these
widgets all right so now we've got a
communication allari between Python and
JavaScript well what if we use some of
these comms and these widgets to to make
visualization because we've got this
nice pipeline right we've got Python
it's talking to backbone why don't we
make Python talk to back go and talk to
d3 saying all right let's write a new
library it's called sticky I would not
recommend using this library for
anything yet but uh there there are it's
a don't put this library into production
but I don't want you to tinker with it
so
all it looks very much like my other
libraries you know initialize a notebook
I pulled in Chris vials micro polar
library here so I that's someone you're
saying all right well Rob this looks a
lot like your other stuff like you're
just rendering a blob of JavaScript into
the notebook that's great well what's
going on behind the scenes here so let's
let's look at some code so if we go into
let's let's start with the let's start
with the widget itself so this is what a
widget looks like an I Python notebook
and basically all that this widget
exists to do is to render Dom element
for us so this widgets rendering a Dom
element the core part of the package
what it's doing here is it say all right
you know i'm going to give give myself a
chart ID i'm going to initialize the
widget j/s which is just basically just
pulling in dependencies i'm going to get
my dom widget i'm going to say when it's
displayed render the dart don't display
beforehand i'm going to say display my
dom widget so the dom widget displays
creates this little Dom element on the
callback that will render the chart and
it will display the chart all right well
what are we doing to render the chart so
I won't show you the microphone when
i'll show you the d3 plus one that I
built so this is what a widget looks
like as far as like implementing so when
I say display self it's basically
figuring out all right basically built
all these attributes on this class in
this class these are all who do they
comb trail it's these are all
communicating these are all trail it's
ipython widget trail it's so each trail
it has a type so in this case they're a
bunch of Unicode types there's a list
type for data on basically serializing
the JSON the rest of the library there's
there's not much exciting going on in
there you know I'm just saying you can
define a line chart a sectarian groups
quatre that sort of thing but for thee
so let's run this guy all right so so
there we go so we defined we define
daddy 3 plus chart basically created a
Dom element came back and said d 3 plus
widget render then applauded it so now
we have a new library you know that we
can you can render in the notebook so
great that's that's good and and I
should mention that this is actually
rendering in the widget area this isn't
taking a blob
of JavaScript and HTML and Andy valine
it into into here it's actually
rendering in the widget area live so you
might be thinking all right well now
that we've got this rendering the widget
area and we've got you know we've got
these layers talking to one another make
a little deeper how can we go deeper
heart all right so what else can we do
this all right well it's like okay well
we're rendering this widget we're
rendering a chart as a widget what if we
create a rigid a widget that renders the
chart as a widget that's like okay well
we've got we've got multiple nesting
layers here but all right so we've got a
chart here we've got a we've got a
widget at the bottom here that lets us
change the data and here's we're kind of
like the brilliant part comes and here's
where the beauty of the column system
comes in is that we're not we don't have
to re-render the chart you know when we
update the data we can pass the new data
to the backbone model and it can use d3s
updating machinery to to nicely
transition that data so change the data
to you got nice transitions you no
longer be rendering and and this is
really really powerful like this is kind
of just touching the surface of what you
can do with that sort of thing show you
another one real quick this is a this is
like a scatter plot this is a kind of a
cool scatter plot because you can
basically you know zoom to multiple
levels of scatter so this is a pinion
ated library this is a neat feature you
don't see many d3 librarian so you've
got Group one within that group you've
got scatter plot you've got points when
you zoom in on this you get more points
so I'm going to update the data let's
say and there we go transitions and I
you know I'm not rear end during the
chart the data is being you know
transition live so think about like the
possibilities for for what this gives us
now we've got Python we've got d3 and
they're talking to each other and the
data can live update so think about all
right what if we wanted to brush brush a
chart and that brush can send back some
filter and constraints of Python Python
can filter a data set that's you know 5
million rows long and then dynamically
update all the charts you know for that
data set and it's not rear end bring
anything it's just communicating back
and forth via the communication protocol
air that's really powerful like suddenly
suddenly we're kind of reaching this
this level of interactivity in a
notebook that it's really compelling so
I'm really excited about it I'm going to
keep working on this library and and you
know work with the ipython guys to get
this built in but you know turn in
conclusion thank you all i think we're
in a really good place for data visitors
it's really exciting because there's a
lot of things that are that we can work
with to build visualizations and there's
more that we can do in the future to
build libraries with interactive
visualization in the notebook and that's
good time to be be visualizing data and
python so thanks
questions microphone yeah it's clear
that d3 is very powerful but um it seems
to me that it's also a little bit slow
when it comes to bigger sets of data and
interactive visualizations so are there
do you think the trees is the clear path
or do you think there may be other
alternatives honestly like I d3 will
work I think d3 like SVG rendering data
sets will be around for a long time I
think the future probably probably is
going to be doing some web GL stuff
that's what's interesting about this be
as it's working with WebGL to surrender
with WebGL the problem is I mean Jason
son was talking about this earlier you
run that pixels right so at some point
you really do be doing data aggregation
for visualizations there's only so many
pixels on the screen and if you're
rendering data points one picks a little
time like it's not a very good
visualization anyway so it really comes
down to the need to aggregate your data
and display something that's useful to
the user so you know the browser we're
kinda always going up those limitations
for how fast JavaScript is and how fast
the browser is working with data but and
as far as like been during SVG elements
but my argument be you shouldn't be
rendering that many SVG elements in the
first place like you should not be
overloading the Dom you should be
careful about about aggregation so
thanks for a really good present eight
up sorry he gave me the microphone side
um so thanks for a great presentation
that's really nice to seek on all these
things loaded in the ipython notebook
actually to that point about SVG versus
non SVG things there is the intermediate
thing which is canvas right yeah which I
think SVG really caps out at a few
thousand elements and many people have
more than just a few thousand elements
but they don't need to put all billion
in the notebook here and so um so I just
want to point out that like bouquet for
instance does render to canvas as again
one of the one of the the only tool kits
I think concept Vincent renders the
camera so does okay I yeah so Doug but
but it's just vague o'er enders to
canvas yeah yeah yeah they make it easy
so and bouquet also can consume baby
there's sort of a graph of the user but
exact but the idea here I think is that
one of the one things I am kind of
curious about is in terms of the data
binding on the backbone side we think
just
overall we've had some discussions with
the ipython guys as well about how do we
get in a common because you're right
that Python to something kind of
reactive model to javascript is the
bridge that everyone needs to cross
whether we're sending json across the
render SVG or whether it's an adjacent
across to update you know canvas
elements essentially in our in our case
okay and I think there'd be you know
it's really great to see the new project
and but I think we should work together
on some of these games because we all
had the same needs there yeah for sure
absolutely absolutely I think we had a
question here's me I was here is if you
would recommend any of these or which
one you to recommend for dynamic updates
and live streaming data that's a that's
a good question i I'd almost say none of
these like a lot of these are kind of
that was my sin yeah I guess but not
really any of them like you know one of
the Vincent's limitations is this kind
of a static render um I feel like
bouquet might actually be the answer to
that question probably because they're
really working a lot I know that like
the history but pochacco and that sort
of thing like there's been a lot of
thought put in how to handle dynamically
updating data so probably none of these
except maybe bouquet will be able to
handle in the future and I talked to
Peter about that there you go there you
go perfect I have a two-part question
what you said about libraries being
opinionated it was really interesting so
the first part of the question is can
you unpack that word a little bit more
do you just need specific you know being
good at specific formats or do you mean
more than that the second part of the
question is what in your opinion is
missing right now what other opinionated
libraries do we need that we don't have
yet yeah it's fair um as far as
opinionated go I mean both opinionated
in design so really you know getting
away from MATLAB style charts and really
you know applying some nice designs you
charge something something that the
designer would build basically I'm so
opinionated design and opinionated and
maybe not trying to boil the ocean
without with your charting library and
say I want to do I want to do five
things really well I'm going to be the
best charting library for doing you know
these five things and I want it to be I
want to make beautiful charts so that
people are happy to use them in their
presentations and use them on
website sorry was your second question
is about what's missing um I really
think that I really think like the the
dynamically linked brushing is the big
one right now being able to being able
to use our communication where and do do
dynamic filtering of data back and forth
between Python and visualization and
we'll get there is just like somebody
needs to build it basically so going
back to your comment on matlab I
replaced a matlab program recently for
real-time instrument I oh and there's
not a lot of good options on the desktop
I'm having a use pie qwt which is
absolutely hideous is there any chance
that any of this stuff can be worked
back into a desktop framework probably
not I mean a lot of this depends pretty
heavily on being in the browser right so
I mean almost everything I basically
everything he lives in the browser
though the whole demo was built in the
browser so I mean not off the top of my
head not that I know of but that's
something I'm not as familiar with
either so hard to say
so ask your practical questions if I
have body codon Muttalib that generates
something that currently looks pitch
black because there are so many plots
want of the other just so much data how
how much time will take for me to
actually if I have it's it's
automatically generated code how much
how easy or how it will be for me to
transform to one of your nicer plots
that allow you to do all those nice
interactive things um depending on the
library are going to use like Seaborn
handles binning pretty well so it'll
handle like heck spinning and square
bidding very nicely for that sort of
thing where you just have this blob of
points and you need to actually bend
them into discrete bins it's hard to say
without looking at your matplotlib code
but normally if you have a bunch
mappable hot lib code and you kind of
have a data schema you can get it in the
seaborne pretty easily as far as turning
the map halt lib code I mean eventually
you need to be you need to bin at
somehow right because right now you've
got this huge is huge pile of points I'm
not as familiar with how matplotlib will
handle that sort of bidding I know it
does I know that Seaborn handles handles
it easily that's what I'd recommend is
like start with a rapper library that
that kind of offers nice syntax we're
doing a sort of thing and then if you
have to go down to the lake you know low
low level matplotlib start looking at
that sort of things like heat maps and
bidding of data points and that sort of
thing
alright well thanks everybody appreciate
it